saïd à cash toul et kamel ça qu'ils sont
devenus amis à l'école des beaux-arts de
tétouan au maroc depuis deux semaines
ils créent côte à côte à la fabrique à
blois le thème de leur exposition les
frontières invisibles
on est des humains avant d'être marocain
en français ou espagnol on n'est pas
concentré sur les les frontier c'est sur
les frontières géographiques nous ce
qu'ils ont envie c'est les frontières
entre les cultures entre les les humains
eux mêmes entre l'humanité voilà c'est
ça qu'on vit sur l'entretien mon travail
basé sur des portraits des silhouettes
et des matériaux symbolique pour
transmettre le message de deux pots
cassés des maisons que pour casser les
frontières entre les mains c'est louise
bras jeune photographe amatrice blésoise
qui a organisé cette résidence à la
fabrique de voix elle avait réalisé une
série de photos en pays berbère pour
elle la résidence artistique est un
outil essentiel à la création
ça les nourrit forcément d'être ailleurs
en fait c'est aussi ça con con qu'on
essaie de mettre en oeuvre en fait
pendant la création pendant la résidence
artistique c'est de se connecter et se
déconnecter mais c'est aussi deux
justement de partager autre chose qu'un
quotidien et donc c'est l'ici et
l'ailleurs aussi le 16 février prochain
saïd et kamel dévoileront leurs oeuvres
créées ici avec deux autres artistes
en attendant samedi le public pourra
découvrir leur travail de création grâce
à une projection sur fond de violences
elle en a l'air
[Musique]